♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans Montarville,
c'est le tableau typique
de la banlieue aisée.
♪ ♪ ♪
La circonscription regroupe
les villes de Saint-Bruno,
Saint-Basile-le-Grand
et Sainte-Julie.
- Est-ce que tu l'envoies
à maman?
- Tout ce que recherchait
Mylène Senécal pour
sa petite famille.
- On est 100 % tombés en amour.
La nature....
- Au début de la pandémie,
elle a trouvé la maison
parfaite à Sainte-Julie.
MYLÈNE SENÉCAL,
résidente de Sainte-Julie
- Ça commençait à être fou,
mais un an plus tard, je peux
dire que je pourrais même plus
acheter ici, comment ça a pris
de la valeur.
- L'accès à la proriété,
les places en garderie,
la lutte contre les changements
climatiques, ce sont
ses priorités pour la campagne
fédérale et qui la font pencher
vers le Parti libéral.
- Mme Pelchat semble amener
ce vent de fraîcheur là,
semble adresser ces points-là.
Donc, si je fais ma...
ma checklist, ça semble
assez intéressant.
- Enchantée!
- Mme Pelchat, c'est elle.
- Je suis candidate
pour le Parti libéral.
- Une courtière immobilière
de la région de 24 ans.
Peu connue, elle mise beaucoup
sur son jeune âge.
MARIE-ÈVE PELCHAT,
candidate, PLC, Montarville, Qc
- Je pense qu'on est rendu, là,
à une époque où on doit contrer
le stéréotype de l'homme blanc
dans la cinquantaine qui est
député, puis on doit surpasser
ça puis amener des nouvelles
idées, une nouvelle vision.
- Une flèche décochée à
son rival, le député bloquiste
sortant, Stephane Bergeron.
- Je fais campagne
un peu partout.
- Ancien député
du Parti Québécois,
c'est un vieux routier.
STÉPHANE BERGERON,
candidat, BQ, Montarville, Qc
- Je suis juste un jeune député
qui a mûri, parce que j'ai
d'abord été élu à l'âge de
28 ans... donc, cet argument-là,
je pense qu'il... il a quand
même une certaine limite.
- Et il a la cote,
surtout chez les plus âgés.
- M. Bergeron, tout le monde
l'aime.
- Je vais aller en terrain
connu pour le Québec.
- J'y vais pour l'équipe,
je suis un gars d'équipe.
M. Bergeron, il est spécial.
Il est disponible.
Il écoute les gens.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Montarville est un champ
de bataille où la lutte se livre
à deuc entre le Parti libéral
et le Bloc québécois,
et ce sera le cas dans
plusieurs banlieues de
la rive sud et de la rive nord,
selon Philippe J.Fournier.
PHILIPPE J. FOURNIER, créateur
de Qc125 et collab. politique
- En 2019, le Bloc québécois
a fait le plein dans
les banlieues de Montréal,
le plein de circonscriptions.
On voit plusieurs luttes serrées
présentement parce que le Bloc
a descendu quelque peu sous
son niveau de 2019. Les libéraux
se sont maintenus et, donc,
Montarville, des banlieues de
Montréal pourraient être en jeu.
- Libéral contre bloquiste,
oui, ça résume à peu près
ma... ma pensée, là.
- Même si Montarville est
la circonscription où le taux
de participation était le plus
élevé au Québec en 2019,
les citoyens ont peu
d'appétit pour les élections.
- On aurait pu attendre
encore un bon moment
avant d'avoir des élections.
Ridicule. Il y en a plein qui
iront pas voter à cause de ça.
- Il me semble qu'il y a
d'autres choses à faire que...
dans le moment, là, que ça.
- Comme quoi?
- Bien, régler la pandémie!
- La pandémie a été
particulièrement difficile pour
Karine Lamarre; elle a dû se
résigner à fermer son restaurant
de Saint-Basile-le-Grand,
malgré l'aide gouvernementale.
KARINE LAMARRE, propriétaire
du restaurant Le Stories
- J'ai aimé le côté proactif,
admettons, du fédéral, toujours
en me méfiant parce que c'est
pas de l'argent donné en cadeau.
Malheureusement, c'était pas
suffisant pour... survivre.
- Tout de même satisfaite
de la gestion de la crise
par les libéraux, son choix
n'est pas encore fait.
- J'hésite toujours,
à ce jour, entre les deux.
- Les indécis sont
encore nombreux...
- C'est difficile de
se faire une opinion.
- C'est vraiment un choix que
je vais faire dernière minute.
- ... et pourraient
tout faire basculer
d'un côté comme de l'autre.
Ici Jacaudray Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, dans la
circonscription de Montarville.